alors restart ou reset ce qui est
certain lui c'est que l'entreprise est
grandement compter et
doit en quelque sorte redoubler
d'efforts pour recréer les conditions de
la confiance auprès de ses communautés
l'entreprise n'a pas vocation à se
substituer au politique
mais ce qui est certain c'est qu'en
l'absence de
gouvernance mondiale on va dire
efficiente sur les grands enjeux de
société
l'entreprise peut contribuer et
participer activement
à l'élaboration et à la mise en oeuvre
de solutions
d'autant plus que l'entreprise est
nativement responsables et les
engagements qui lui sont demandées
aujourd'hui lui permet de se
réapproprier le sens de ce que
entreprendre signifie
l'origine du mot
entreprendre l'origine du mot
finalement
consiste
du point de vue de l'activité
entrepreneuriale consiste à
prendre quelque chose entre ses mains
tenir quelque chose entre ses mains pour
le maîtriser le façonner le développer
et le sens fixé par lusage dès le xvème
siècle à ceux ci quant à lui le mot à la
prise de risque commune et solidaire
entreprendre c'est prendre un risque
entre soi c'est à dire ensemble
et la
habilité de l'entrepreneur elle est
partagée est totale parce que en cas
d'échec c'est la ruine tout simplement
au 19e siècle
une innovation juridique la société
anonyme qui permet l'émergence de
l'actionnariat
lequel encourage finalement les
entrepreneurs à rassembler d'autres
capitaux clés leur auprès de banques
d'investisseurs publics privés pour
financer le développement de leur
entreprise
cette capacité à injecter du capital
dans les entreprises a permis un
développement sans précédent
mais cela aussi distendu le rôle de
l'actionnaire qui est devenu au fil du
temps
un investisseur
et puisque
il est devenu investisseurs quelque part
la société la structure juridique la
société anonyme à limiter sa
responsabilité
il n'est plus responsable sur ses biens
propres
sa seule responsabilité finalement c'est
son apport financier
et puisque mais en même temps et c'est
fondamental de le dire c'est aussi cela
la société anonyme qui a permis l'esprit
d'entreprise de libérer l'esprit
d'entreprise et puisque l'investisseur
n'est plus responsable sur ses biens
propres mais sur son apport financier
eh bien il s'est passé quelque chose la
responsabilité c'est naturellement
déplacer vers l'entreprise en passant de
la qualité totale à la gouvernance
d'entreprise pour arriver in fine et à
la responsabilité sociétale des
entreprises finalement le nouveau statut
de société à mission à travers la loi
pacte promulgué fin 2019 début 2020 et
bien traduit bien ce transfert de
responsabilité
et répond grandement aux attentes des
citoyens
cela étant on ne peut pas résumer une
entreprise à son simple statut juridique
une entreprise
ça va au delà de son simple statut
juridique une entreprise peut développer
d'autres formes de capitaux que l'on
obtient à travers la création collective
l'innovation la production innovatrice
le la culture des valeurs la réinvention
des organisations au delà du capital
financier il faut surtout considérer le
capital humain
est quelque part
la raison d'être
permet de considérer ce capital humain
en réinjectant du sens dans l'entreprise
pour m les organisations en mouvement et
le mouvement suscite l'adhésion
donc en ce sens ce nouveau statut à
travers sa raison d'être répond
grandement à mettre l'entreprise en
mouvement dans un monde d'incertitude
totale
volatiles complexe
où le brouillard et omniprésent et le
rôle du dirigeant et bien c'est
d'éclairer la voient même en l'absence
de contraintes juridiques ou
réglementaires donc la raison d'être est
quelque chose d'absolument essentielle
pour contribuer justement à mettre
l'entreprise en mouvement les
organisations en mouvement
il ya des fondamentaux à respecter pour
déterminer une raison d'être qui soit de
nature à inspirer le plus grand nombre
le premier il faut aller puiser dans les
racines de la société
l'expérience du fondateur en quelque
sorte
les racines son adn ses origines
c'est essentiel si on veut rendre le
projet d'entreprise authentique
concernant mon grand père
mon grand père en fait a vécu une
expérience à l'âge de 14 ans en fait mon
grand père a toujours eu des problèmes
de santé plutôt grave à tel point que
ses parents étaient obligés de lui faire
l'école à la maison
sauf que à l'âge de 14 ans son père
décède et il part se réfugier en forêt
non pas qu'ils dormaient dans les bois
mais il passait ses journées en forêt et
ça ça lui a procuré une forme
d'apaisement de consolation voire de
protection est en fait à l'âge de 14 ans
il a pris conscience que la nature avait
un impact positif sur notre bien-être et
en retour il a eu envie d'agir en faveur
de la nature et donc en fait tout son
projet entrepreneurial découle de cette
expérience qu'il a vécu à l'âge de 14
ans suite au décès de son papa
donc il faut aller puiser dans les
racines de la société ou de
l'entrepreneur pour rendre le projet
authentique deuxième principe
auquel il faut répondre lorsque l'on
travaille sur sa raison d'être s'assurer
que
le défi le combat dans lequel on engage
l'entreprise répond aux défis futurs et
actuels
la nature vouloir reconnecter les femmes
les hommes à la nature dans un monde de
plus en plus urbanisée et cerné par la
technologie prend tout son sens
et d'ailleurs cette urbanisation
croissante est probablement la source
d'un grand nombre de troubles
auxquels nous pouvons répondre à travers
une scène reconnexion à la nature
sachant qu'il n'y a pas de petite ou de
grande expérience de nature
troisième élément
nous vivons dans un monde de
transformation on parle de
transformation en permanence il faut
transformer les business models adapter
nos entreprises
autant d'aujourd'hui
et pour autant il faut que tout cela
toutes ces transformations
s'opère sur un socle de valeurs qui lui
ne doit pas varier dans le temps
c'est essentiel si on veut être en
capacité de capter son organisation
notamment dans la durée
enfin quatrième critère qui plus
peut-être une petite
pas anecdotes mais
probablement moins important que les
trois premiers pour définir sa raison
d'être c'est un exercice en réalité une
fois qu'on a formalisé sa raison d'être
il faut l'inscrire sur le papier à
en-tête de son principal concurrent et
s'il peut se l'approprier
son principal concurrent
il ya deux sion qui s'offre à nous
recommencer l'exercice de rédaction de
la raison d'être ou alors racheter son
concurrent
ces quatre critères sont essentielles
pour être en capacité de délivrer dans
l'organisation une raison dette qui va
susciter de l'engagement de la fierté
d'appartenance et mettre l'organisation
en mouvement
le statut de société à mission il ya
trois étages pour acquérir
ce statut le premier il s'impose à
toutes les sociétés
c'est l'objet social élargi qui prend en
compte les sujets environnementaux et
sociétaux et non plus seulement la
performance économique le deuxième c'est
la raison d'être et c'est utile de
s'interroger sur la raison d'être de son
entreprise parce que figurez vous que la
raison d'être d'une entreprise c'est une
raison d'y être pour l'ensemble des
collaboratrices et des collaborateurs de
l'entreprise
et enfin le statut de société à mission
le dernier étage de la fusée
qui lui est plus contraignant parce que
concrètement
il faut mettre en place un comité de
mission qui doit rédiger un rapport
pour mesurer l'état d'avancement de
l'entreprise au regard des objectifs
qu'elle s'est fixés par rapport à son
propre combat sa raison d'être et tout
cela doit être certifié par un organisme
tiers indépendant mais c'est ce qui
donne toute la légitimité
le démarche donc pour résumer je dirais
que à travers la loi pacte et le statut
de société à mission pour la première
fois de son histoire la culture
d'entreprise vient de trouver un support
juridique
et que si la raison d'être c'est du miel
le statut de société à mission c'est de
la gelée royale